bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 lectus sur TV film Le
Journal de la rédaction 26 minutes pour
faire le tour 2 l'actualité est local et
dans l'actualité du jour justement
irresponsable illégitime l'opération de
blocage des axes routiers en région
parisienne ce matin par les agriculteurs
a fait réagir la classe politique et les
usagers des agriculteurs en colère
contre les cotaxes et plus généralement
contre la politique menée actuellement
nous les entendons dans un instant la
14e édition de la Semaine école
entreprise c'est jusqu'à demain
l'occasion de sensibiliser collégiens et
lycéens au monde de l'entreprise à
travers des échanges sur ses valeurs
parmi les opérations une visite attrape
pour des jeunes élèves dans l'entreprise
Volvo et puis l'émission Masterchef sur
TF1 rencontre toujours un vif succès
pour son édition 2013 l'une des
candidates a grandi dans les Yvelines
Marie-Hélène Mahé avant de participer au
prochain numéro vendredi aller ce soir
l'invité du 7 8 l'actu
du jour ce sont ces voitures sur la
nationale 10 en pleine manoeuvre des
demi-tours à hauteur de l'hôtel de ville
de Trappes pour ses automobilistes
cherchant peu avant 10h30 ce matin à
contourner le barrage en place par les
agriculteurs et les agriculteurs qui
souhaitaient ainsi obtenir la démission
de leur ministre Stéphane Le Foll et
dénoncer également les hausses des
charges sociales c'est d'ailleurs
l'ensemble de la profession en
Île-de-France qui était mobilisée et on
va détailler cette matinée d'action dans
un instant je vous propose tout d'abord
d'écouter et le représentant du syndicat
agricole FDSEA
l'agriculture céréalière en France est
un vecteur économique extrêmement
important et Monsieur Le Foll n'en tient
pas compte demain si nous vivons plus de
notre métier c'est tout le secteur amont
et aval de l'économie française qui va
s'écrouler au niveau de du milieu
agricole voilà c'est très simple comme
message et c'est un message qu'il faut
absolument que les gens arrivent à
comprendre les agriculteurs franciliens
qui étaient donc mobilisés en
Île-de-France 7 points de blocage ce
matin donc trois rien que dans les
Yvelines à hauteur des pônes de menthe
mais on vient de le voir également sur
la nationale 10 entre Rambouillet et
trappes ou encore la nationale 12 vers
joueur Pontchartrain en venant de Dreux
le point sur cette mobilisation avec les
équipes de la rédaction
la première chercher à charge sociale il
faudra nous l'expliquer c'est pas
possible 7 points de blocage en
Île-de-France dont trois rien que pour
les Yvelines les organisateurs se
félicitent de la mobilisation réclame
leur ras-le-bol fiscal un gros
ras-le-bol du ministre un gros
ras-le-bol de cette décroissance une un
gros ras-le-bol de voir ce pays qui
n'avance plus qu'on ne crée plus
d'emploi alors le secteur agricole est
touché mais on sait bien que c'est tous
les autres secteurs d'activité de la
France qui est qui est par terre il faut
absolument que Monsieur Hollande
entendent le bon sens agricole on va
dans le mur on va dans le mur pour que
nous on le voit les petits d'en bas
là-haut faut quand même qu'ils ouvrent
les yeux c'est pas possible de tenir
comme ça vers 9h30 les forces de l'ordre
organisent le départ des voitures elles
prendront la nationale 12 à contresens
10 heures la décision est prise de lever
le blocus les tracteurs reprennent leur
route direction cette fois la nationale
10 pour rejoindre un autre cortège
partie lui des Essarts-le-Roi les
tracteurs se retrouvent à hauteur de la
verrière puis de Trappes vers le
Pavillon Bleu il est maintenant 10h30 la
situation est totalement bloquée seule
quelques scooters peuvent passer les
automobilistes prennent leur mal en
patience même si pour certains c'était
très difficile à aller travailler ce
matin on peut comprendre leur
manifestations mais de l'autre côté on
est pénalisé également parce que on doit
partir travailler on a plein de
contraintes qui font partie donc mais on
subit comme tout le monde et on attend
on patiente
au fait donc tant plus que
malheureusement il défendent leur pain
comme on dirait mais qu'est-ce qui paye
tout ça c'est le contribuable quelque
part donc nous sommes nous-mêmes prions
nos tâches en fin de matinée les
automobilistes sont invités à prendre la
nationale à contresens opération blocage
des routes réussis et les agriculteurs
ne veulent pas lâcher la pression et une
manifestation nationale est prévue le 29
novembre les fédérations présentent ce
matin appellent les différentes
corporations à se regrouper entre elles
et cette journée de mobilisation a été
endeuillée un pompier de 29 ans se
rendant à son travail dans le Val-d'Oise
a trouvé la mort en percutant un camion
à cause des ralentissements causés par
ces barrages agricoles c'est ce
qu'affirme en tout cas le ministre
délégué au transport Frédéric Cuvillier
une enquête a été ouverte
un jeune qui a sûrement dû perdre un peu
son sang-froid qui a pris une bande
d'art d'urgence ma chose qu'on doit pas
faire bon malheureusement c'est
intervenu sur un ralentissement le
milieu agricole le déplore bon
malheureusement on n'est pas responsable
de tous les accidents qui peut avoir
lieu en Île-de-France les gens de du Val
d'Oise ont levé par par des sens leur
barrage nous on est resté extrêmement
sobre dans notre dans notre intervention
justement un peu en mémoire de de cette
personne qui est décédée sur la route
bon c'est toujours très dramatique
on quitte le monde agricole et ses
revendications pour celui de
l'entreprise renforcer les liens avec
l'école est devenu une priorité c'est
dans ce cadre que se tient la semaine
école entreprise c'est même la 14e
édition pas question ici de stage
d'observation pour les collégiens mais
plutôt des échanges avec les
professionnels exemple sur l'une des
opérations à Trappes dans les locaux du
constructeur automobile Volvo villemann
ces élèves de troisième du Lycée Henri
Matisse à trappe ont quitté ce mercredi
leur salle de classe à la place d'un
cours théorique ils ont visité
l'entreprise Volvo dans un premier temps
une explication de l'activité de la
société et de ses métiers principalement
dans le domaine de la maintenance
deuxième étape l'atelier ou les
techniciens du groupe s'occupent de
réparer ou d'entretenir ses gros engins
de travaux publics un cours pas comme
les autres et le concept semble
intéresser les élèves ce qui est bien ce
qu'on découvre des métiers et ça nous
aide plus tard quoi pour notre avenir et
c'est intéressant parce que on est dans
une troisième découverte pro donc comme
ça on découvre plein de métiers et je
trouve ça intéressant malgré quelques
flocons les élèves les plus intéressés
visitent le parc des machines certains
découvrent ici de nouvelles perspectives
d'avenir je vois que vous jouez une
marque avec des engins et je connaissais
que les voitures pour l'instant j'ai
envie de faire un mécanicien auto
et peut-être que plus tard mécanicien de
engin comme ça objectif à temps pour
l'entreprise car son activité principale
la maintenance TP est trop souvent
méconnu du grand public nous on fait ces
actions là parce qu'on a besoin de
remplir nos filières on a vraiment un
manque de technicien
quand on en cherche des fois on met 6
mois à trouver un bon technicien un
secteur qui recrute et qui propose aux
débutants un salaire de base de 1700
euros
quand l'économie veille à prendre soin
de l'environnement l'entreprise autocar
Dominique commercialise depuis peu peak
green depuis Buc et c'est un succès au
point de faire de l'ombre à la RATP le
concept des minibus 100% électrique
Olivier Maniscalco
15e est un une colline
on doit toujours monter quand on va vers
la porte de Versailles quelle que soit
la solution empruntée donc celle là est
bien c'est un peu spécialisé pour les
gens vraiment avec le mobilité réduite
avec
je sais pas quoi petit trajectoire entre
deux
pour Marie et Valentin le courant semble
passer avec les minibus électriques
bigrin en circulation depuis un mois
dans le 15e arrondissement de Paris ces
petits véhicules colorés silencieux ont
réussi un gros coup détrôner pour la
première fois depuis 1949 la RATP sur le
pavé parisien propriété de l'entreprise
autocar de Munich basée à Buc les bus
bigrine sont le fruit d'un
investissement risqué Patrick minucci
PDG de la société prend le pari d'en
acheter 3 ou constructeur italien
zeusbreda en novembre 2009 il les
propose dans la foulée à ses clients le
ministère de la Santé Microsoft safran
France Télévisions et maintenant la
Mairie du 15e tous se montrent séduits
et adhère au projet bigrin tous ces
clients ont été conquis nous avons pu
leur proposer une alternative électrique
à ce qu'ils avaient jusque jusqu'à lors
à savoir du transport thermique et
équivalent mais aujourd'hui nous sommes
en transport propre avec du Zéro
d'émission de CO2 et politique commence
à mettre des feuilles de route qui me
paraissent un peu durable
donc ça c'est une des grosses clés parce
que les industriels ont besoin d'un feu
vert dans la durée pour pour construire
des véhicules ils savent le faire et je
pense que c'est bien parti tout ce qui
concerne le ramassage de personnes de
proximité le transport dans les
collectivités locales en hypersens
notamment peut être parfaitement exécuté
avec ce type de matériel donc
effectivement c'est une partie de
l'avenir du transport collectif donc
avec ce transport propre déjà installé
en région à l'île de Ré dans les
Pyrénées et les Alpes l'entreprise
yvelinoise va continuer son
développement notamment en Île-de-France
et dans de nouveaux arrondissements
parisiens avec un parc d'une vingtaine
de bus 100% électrique bigrine se
positionne en tout cas déjà comme le
leader européen en la matière
on passe à l'invité de ce journal
Marie-Hélène bonsoir vous êtes candidate
de l'émission Masterchef sur TF1 vous
faites partie des six participantes
encore en lice on vous retrouvera donc
vendredi soir pour un nouveau numéro de
nouvelles épreuves on va tout de suite
préciser les choses parce que vous êtes
présentés comme une candidate venant
d'Amiens c'est effectivement que vous
résidez vous travaillez mais vous avez
grandi dans les Yvelines j'ai grandi
dans les départements voilà au Chesnay
vous avez fait vos études à Versailles
au lycée Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
l'université étudiante en lettres
modernes mais loin de la cuisine les
lettres pourquoi les lettres bah parce
que je suis journaliste dans la vie donc
voilà pourquoi les lettres et pourquoi
Masterchef tout simplement parce que
j'aimerais être journaliste culinaire
voilà concilier les deux les deux
passions faire ensuite d'un métier
également cette passion pour la pour la
cuisine elle vient d'où cette passion
pour la cuisine bah elle vient de
l'enfance tout simplement comme beaucoup
je pense c'est cuisiné avec ma
grand-mère au début avec ma maman des
biscuits des gâteaux des choses pas
compliquées au début puis après
l'adolescent j'ai pas mal cuis aussi
avec mon frère des choses plus ou moins
réussies et après moi même toute seule
voilà je peux passer des heures en
cuisine ça me dérange pas alors vous
souhaitez concilier cuisine journaliste
mais vous nous l'avez dit va devenir
journaliste culinaire est-ce que ça vous
a ouvert des portes jusqu'à présent ce
passage dans l'émission MasterChef pour
le moment c'est vrai que je suis très
concentré sur le sur l'émission en
elle-même j'ai des idées j'ai des
projets voilà je pense qu'il y aura pas
trop de mal à ce qu'on les entendent à
ce qu'on m'écoute pour le moment ça en
est encore au stade de d'écriture de
projet donc faciliter les projets est-ce
que c'était difficile auparavant lorsque
vous vouliez vous vous lancez justement
dans le journalisme culinaire jusqu'à
présent c'était plutôt non et vous vous
êtes bon bah j'ai utilisé un autre biais
c'est vrai que c'est un milieu qui fait
envie donc je suis pas la seule à
vouloir le faire il y a beaucoup
d'appeler c'est ça je délu voilà donc
j'espère que d'avoir participé à cette
émission va m'aider bien sûr mais
au-delà de ça ça a confirmé aussi mon
envie c'était un peu le test masterche
4ème saison vous étiez adepte de cette
émission vous la regardiez je regardais
oui oui et je me disais commencer de
vivre de l'intérieur maintenant je le
sais vous allez nous dire tout à l'heure
comment c'est justement de l'intérieur
alors de votre présentation dans cette
émission vous expliquer que votre truc
c'était plutôt la pâtisserie vous auriez
aussi pu faire meilleur pâtissier
polyvalente finalement et quand je
regarde le meilleur pâtissier parce que
je regarde aussi je me dis eux ils sont
vraiment très pointus quand même bon moi
je fais de très belles choses mais je
dirais que je suis assez polyvalente
entre la cuisine et la pâtisserie entre
le salé et le sucre on va juste faire
une petite pause vous allez nous dire
comment ça se passe de l'Intérieur
comment sont les chefs les jurés avec
vous auparavant notre question du jour
appréciez-vous êtes-vous fans de ces
différentes émissions culinaires vos
réponses
avec Faustine Bollaert là sur les les
gâteaux pour axé sur la pâtisserie parce
que ça apprend plein de choses et puis
ça permet de voir qu'il y a des gens
novices qui savent faire de la
pâtisserie de façon exceptionnelle il
m'est arrivé de regarder mais pas pas de
façon
assidue je préfère aller au restaurant
que de m'aventurer dans la cuisine
toutes celles qui parlent de recettes et
qui sont explicatives surtout parce que
j'adore cuisiner lesquels
j'ai pas de titre en tête mais j'aime
bien les carnets de Julie par exemple je
crois que c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle ça ne m'intéresse pas c'est la
compétition qui m'intéresse pas je
préfère voir les recettes tout
simplement mais bon tout ce qui est sur
Oui TF1 M6 ou ces choses là non ça
m'intéresse pas du tout Top Chef comme
ça moi j'aime bien de temps en temps ça
change qu'est-ce que vous aimez dans ces
émissions le dynamisme des gens pour
réaliser quelque chose de correct je ne
regarde pas
ça m'intéresse pas non non pourtant je
suis j'aime bien la cuisine j'aime bien
manger mais non ça ne m'intéresse pas
alors il y a des gens qui n'aiment pas
malgré tout parce qu'il y en a quand
même quelques-uns parce que il y a
l'aspect compétition aussi il y a
vraiment cet aspect compétition de
l'intérieur c'est comment vous le vivez
c'est il y a une rivalité entre chacun
des candidats moi je dirais que la
compétition je la ressens dans l'atelier
quand on voilà on a une nouvelle épreuve
on nous demande de cuisiner là on
ressent la compétition sinon en dehors
moi personnellement non voilà je me suis
fait des je me suis fait des amis quand
même on n'est pas là uniquement pour se
tirer dans les pattes non non pas
d'ennemis voilà pas non plus les amis
avec tout le monde faut pas le monde des
bisounours non plus mais je me suis fait
des très belles amitiés et ça reste un
concours voilà il y a un seul gagnant
mais on est des adultes c'est-à-dire que
on a beau s'apprécier voilà une fois
qu'on est dans l'épreuve on sait très
bien que personne se fera de cadeau le
public qui apprécie globalement on l'a
entendu en ces émissions de cuisine
d'ailleurs en ce moment vous allez le
rencontrer ce public hier vous étiez à
Vélizy 2 au centre commercial pour des
animations lors d'un village des saveurs
dans un centre commercial vous avez
réalisé quoi comme demain j'y serai
encore donc vendredi demain de 11 à 13
et donc j'ai proposé de la pâte à choux
crème pâtissière et caramel donc des
bases des bases mais qui permettent de
réaliser beaucoup de choses la pâte à
choux on peut faire du sucré du salé les
gougères par exemple au fromage ou au
saumon enfin on peut mettre ce qu'on
veut dedans généralement les choux ça à
la cote en soirée ça part noël arrive
bientôt les idées de recettes bah voilà
ce village des saveurs votre
démonstration nouvelle démonstration
vous l'avez dit c'est vendredi vendredi
entre 11h et 13h et 13h les gens vous
demandent quoi ensuite ils viennent vous
voir pourquoi parce que pour demander
des conseils pour vous pas cette
émission oui pose des questions sur les
missions bien sûr parce que ça ils
peuvent poser la question après je
répondrai pas de toute façon personne
mais non c'est plus des conseils aussi
une dame qui est venue me voir voilà
elle me fait je fais une tarte aux
fraises comment faire briller mes
fraises caresses brillantes donc c'est
des petits trucs comme ça voilà on
échange sur la cuisine et c'est tout ce
que j'aime justement dans dans la
cuisine c'est échanger et on me demande
en régie je vais tout vous dire c'est
comment comment on fait attention
cool sur les tartes mais moi je trouve
ça pas bon c'est très épais voilà moi je
prends tout simplement de la confiture
groseille ou abricot que je dilue avec
un peu d'eau et au pinceau je nappe les
fruits et du coup ça donne une brillance
voilà c'était le Conseil Masterchef de
la soirée dans ce journal on traite
décidément de tous les sujets ce soir
ceux qui ne pourront pas les au centre
commercial Vélizy 2 ils auront aussi
l'occasion de goûter à votre cuisine
cette fois-ci à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
puisque le patron du bistrot du théâtre
vous a offert à ouvrir sa cuisine vous
allez préparer le menu du 28 novembre
vous connaissez cet établissement
lorsque vous étiez étudiante à 50 ans
vous de se retourner cette fois-ci pour
préparer ce menu du 28 ce sera quoi ce
menu du 28 alors c'est un menu qui me
ressemble voilà j'ai voulu faire des
plats que les gens goûtent ma cuisine
donc en entrée il y aura un feuilleté
chèvre échalote confite avec un mesclin
acidulé ensuite on passe à la blanquette
de veau à l'ancienne puisque par le pur
des hasards j'ai dû la cuisiner deux
fois dans l'émission et que du coup ça
c'est devenu un peu un plat phare de ma
cuisine à mes dépens mais bon j'adore la
blanquette de veau voilà et en dessert
un basique un moelleux au chocolat avec
du caramel caramel beurre demi-sel si
vous voulez vous pouvez encore réserver
bien sûr pour cette soirée à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux au bistrot du
théâtre vous capitalisez bien sur cette
notoriété indécente centre commercial
cette opération au bistrot du théâtre ça
vous a ouvert d'autres perspectives oui
bah c'est vrai que du coup on nous ouvre
les portes de restaurant voilà on va
cuisiner avec des professionnels moi
personnellement à chaque fois je suis
très heureuse je suis allée du côté de
Bordeaux le week-end dernier j'ai
cuisiné avec quatre autres candidats qui
sont donc des amis et mais voilà c'est
on est des amateurs donc on se met pas
en avant rien du tout moi je continue à
apprendre justement en faisant ce type
de soirée parce que je suis au contact
de professionnelle moi j'ai la passion
j'ai l'envie le travail bien fait pour
que ça s'arrête aussi que la notoriété
disparaître disparaissent pardon
rapidement moi c'est pas la notoriété
qui m'intéresse voilà c'est toujours
très agréable le retour des gens mais
moi c'est pas voilà qu'on parle de moi
sur pour faire le buzz entre guillemets
je veux que ça se transforme en travail
réellement comment ça se passe c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose je
voulais pas encore posé comment ça se
passe de l'intérieur les chefs sont-ils
si méchant non non les chefs ne sont pas
si méchants mais il en mette parce que
c'est normal ce qu'on a pas le temps non
plus de traîner et puis ils ont envie
qu'on s'améliore donc quelque part les
réflexions les remarques elles sont là
pour nous pour nous faire aller de
l'avant et moi j'ai toujours bien pris
les choses et de toute façon quand ils
nous disent quelque chose ils ont raison
je vous propose de rester encore un
petit peu avec nous on va regarder ce
reportage à présent d'un autre concours
de cuisine qui s'est déroulé dans les
Yvelines et quatre candidats cuisiniers
amateurs présélectionnés pour participer
à ce battle c'est au Palais des Congrès
à Versailles à partir d'un produit phare
ils avaient seulement 15 minutes pour
préparer cuire dressé et présenter au
jury leurs Rochette recette c'était
l'occasion de lancer une opération good
Yvelines dans le département
beaucoup de concentration pour David il
est breton et vient participer au
premier battle de cuisine organisé dans
le cadre de l'opération good Yvelines ce
négociateur immobilier est un passionné
de cuisine présélectionnés sur internet
il a envie de bien faire c'est une
passion après un tremplin pourquoi pas
vous avez fait la vie est fait
d'opportunités donc aujourd'hui son
étude face
à Luke pod dîner presque parfait dans la
vie Francis travaille dans une agence de
publicité 4 cuisiniers amateurs qui
doivent préparer des recettes en 15
minutes seulement à partir de produits
locaux un fromage frais de
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse des champignons
de Paris de Montesson et du miel des
Yvelines ces produits quand même
particulier à travailler à sublimer et
du coup on a il faut vraiment faire
preuve d'imagination et d'essayer de
trouver à la fois d'originalité
peut-être dans les mélanges et les
saveurs et trouver peut-être deux trois
astuces qui peuvent être techniques qui
peuvent permettre de se démarquer mais
c'est vrai que ça va très très vite
alors côté pour les conseillers devrait
chef David était épaulé par Laurent
Trochain installé au
Tremblay-sur-Mauldre et le restaurateur
le reconnaît la cuisine est une valeur
sûre on aime le produit on aime le bon
produit et on aime manger et de plus en
plus on a vu revenir en même temps les
ménagers refaire à manger aujourd'hui
des cuisiniers amateurs
font aussi bien ou mieux je veux dire
que certains restaurants c'est pour ça
que certains désertent les restaurants
parce qu'il qui font assez à manger chez
eux parmi les conseils que Laurent a
distillé ce jour-là surtout s'amuser et
prendre du plaisir les joutes culinaires
ont été remportés cocorico par une
yvelinoise lorcane de Vélizy l'opération
good Yvelines se poursuit jusqu'au 1er
décembre avec des ateliers de cuisine
des menus spéciaux toujours à partir de
produits locaux
15 minutes avec des produits locaux
c'est faisable est-ce qu'il y a un
produit dans le département que vous
aimeriez cuisiner on a eu une épreuve
sur les produits
Île-de-France voilà la volaille et le
boudin mais c'est vrai que le boudin
noir j'aime beaucoup le travailler merci
Marie-Hélène MAE qui est donc candidate
Masterchef cette saison sur TF1 vendredi
soir vendredi midi au centre commercial
Vélizy 2 et puis également le village
pour ce village des saveurs et puis
également le 28 novembre au bistrot du
théâtre j'ajoute que vous serez même ce
week-end à Disneyland non pas pour les
loisirs mais pour accompagner des
enfants ça va être une journée de
loisirs quand même ça me fait très
plaisir d'y aller en tout cas c'est une
opération organisée par l'association le
Secours populaire merci à vous et bonne
chance pour la suite de cette
compétition autre sujet pour terminer ce
journal on parlait cuisine on va parler
et sport maintenant le sport scolaire
qui se porte bien c'est même la
troisième instance sportive en nombre
d'adhérents en France avec plus d'un
million de licenciés derrière la
Fédération et de football ou encore
celle de tennis 500 de ses adhérents à
l'UNSS sur ce secteur couvrant et
l'encours jusqu'à la manière se sont
retrouvés dans cette fin de semaine le
reportage les images de cette
compétition
6 course à pied par catégorie d'âge pour
départager les représentants du district
du NSS couvrant les collèges d'Élancourt
Coignières ou encore de Trappes l'UNSS
l'Union nationale du sport scolaire qui
depuis 1932 promeux la valeur éducative
du sport et l'apprentissage de la vie
associative par les élèves le cross dans
le district de Maurepas en fait on
considère nous les profs que c'est un
des temps forts de l'année pour les
élèves qui sont licenciés dans les
collèges et le deuxième temps fort ça
concerne le raid du NSS qu'on organise à
la base de loisirs en fin d'année et
donc là on nous est le fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui mais on demande à tous les
licenciers de venir et de participer
pour pour réussir cette course au total
500 élèves se sont affrontés ici au parc
Cousteau de la verrière autour de ses
idées de compétition et de
responsabilisation et ils ont pris les
choses très au sérieux au départ comme à
l'arrivée ça va être dur parce que déjà
de l'autre côté aussi ça c'est dans
l'herbe ça glisse donc bref faudra se
méfier pour pasteur de la cheville et
tout
j'ai couru 4 km tous les week-ends
le journal revient demain vendredi et il
sera notamment question dans ce point
sur l'actualité locale de l'avenir du
centre commercial Skywest à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le projet de
refonte baptisé carré privé ouest autour
du luxe à prix réduit serait abandonné
les propriétaires amersson et codig de
ce projet de rénovation parlent eux de
la journée en raison de recours Aurélie
maintenant en question de rapprochement
de Skywest au centre historique espace
Saint-Quentin pour posséder par la même
compagnie c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée si
vous nous suivez en direct vous avez
rendez-vous à présent avec Claire
Cambier pour fileco